foreign
previously on congratulations which one
which one's this up what everyone says
so oh yeah
yeah where does it say soap on here
there you go I said that where does it
say something crazy
[Music]
you uh are a great guy and you've really
uh you know you're a good person and
um
um you know I'm lucky to know you and
[ __ ] and I do keep people in my circle
now that I really care about and
um you know I love you bro I love you
too yeah
does that make you feel weird when I say
I love you not at all so uh all right so
if you say I love you to me and then I
say I love you too does that make you
feel weird no okay
that's fairly new for me though like I
did not feel weird doing that yeah
because you know masculine like I'm an
alpha you're an alpha I mean
but I'm kind of yeah and it's it's not
we're not really taught to love our
friends like we're not really taught to
say I love you and I mean and not be
like weird about it you know but
yeah I've become more comfortable doing
that in the last few years because you
know I'm I'm three four years older than
you two or three years older I don't
know and I'm I'm losing people and
I don't you mean they're dying yeah yeah
and and and I I love so many people but
I don't spend the time to make to let
them know that because a lot of times
I'm like well if I tell them that like I
don't know how they're going to react to
it and I don't want to make them feel
like they have to say I love you back or
like why is he calling me out of the
blue just to tell me that he loves me
like that's weird is everything okay
like is he sick I gotta want to alarm
people but like I've known you long
enough and and the people around me that
I've just gotten used to saying that
I've just gotten used to saying man I
love you because I I do and and I want
you to know that and I want the people
close to me to know that and how long
have you been doing that just a couple
of the last few years I think right
before the pandemic and you're saying it
doesn't make you feel weird
it doesn't anymore because I what what
made me feel weird early on is like oh
how is that gonna make them feel or how
is that or how are they going to
perceive me like am I do they think that
I'm like I said do they think I'm sick
or do they think I'm I'm being a [ __ ]
or whatever but like I don't care what
they think as long as they know that I'm
sending this to them hey I love you and
you don't have to say it back you don't
even have to respond to my text or my
email or whatever but I just want you to
know that
um it makes me feel good it makes me
feel good to send a uh send something to
someone not necessarily I love you but
something meaningful or grateful or
whatever without thinking well are they
going to respond like are they gonna how
come they haven't call me back that's
not why I'm doing it I'm doing it
because I think it's important to let
them know how I feel about them yeah I
tell people that has to be you do I do
but it's fairly new though right some uh
I think with any sort of like you know
friendship and saying
I love you
you know it doesn't make me feel weird
to say it it does make me feel sometimes
bunched up to
um
like
look in your eyes or like to to really
if you say it and I say it then that's a
full connection and because it's so real
and I like to like keep my walls up you
know I'm I'm trying to not So Much
Anymore and I've done a lot of [ __ ]
therapy and [ __ ] but like
to not do that is tough because I think
it's kind of the same it comes from the
same thing as like sitting alone and
being with yourself is just it can be
uncomfortable if you're confronting
feelings yeah and um so it's a little
bit uh
it's a little bit
yeah it does make me feel a certain way
it's not like bad and I you know it's
weird too because like
my family like growing up like my dad
and my mom would always tell me they
love me it's not like a you know yeah so
I don't know where along the way I
picked that up did you ever do it do you
ever you didn't say it to your friends I
mean I did yeah but but yeah I kind of
always have but but maybe not in my 20s
but like
in my 30s I would do it because I was
like dude I do love them but I would
spend time thinking like
you know we all have sometimes thoughts
where it's just like why did I think of
that but like I would think of like okay
like I remember there were times where I
would spend thinking like what is it
like to miss someone like what does it
mean to miss someone like does it mean I
get that does it mean you want to see
them again yeah does it mean that you
feel
like it's been too long and there's an
actual like yearning you have to be with
them and I remember thinking like
I don't know what it's like
to actually maybe miss someone yeah you
know like when I was in you know I was
in college for eight months or when I
when I'm on the road like do I miss like
X's that I've had would I miss being
away from them
most of the time it was the answer was
no you know and I would say it but
I I didn't know how that felt or what
that meant and I think it's probably
because I didn't let people in you know
100 I kept them at an arm's length so I
didn't have I couldn't develop missing
somebody because I never really let them
in to love them yeah
and now I think well first of all I
think having my son just opened me the
[ __ ] up I mean I was talking about it to
my therapist and and I was like telling
her a version of this about how I keep
people at a distance and walls up and
[ __ ] and she was like oh you're [ __ ]
now that you have Calvin she literally
said and I was like yeah you're right
and I I laughed because you you know I
am not the kind of person that can be
away from my son and not you know there
are people that can just have kids and
and not really you know
be uh the type of person that is fit to
be a dad but I am yeah and I didn't know
that but it turns out I am and now with
Calvin
I miss him I I actually feel what it's
like to miss him and because of that it
opens up my world to
love and and being around other people
and actually loving them and connecting
with them
and I do miss them now I know what it
feels like to miss someone but I don't
feel like I did until I into the past
few years and I I think Calvin has a
huge reason is a huge reason because I
don't think it's all of it but you know
I've obviously done a lot of work on
myself and [ __ ] but like it's it's a
really wild fantastic thing to feel and
and and what's hard about it is it
actually
hurts yeah like you you develop this
love and you develop this realness and
this you know people would always say
like what's the what's the meaning of
life and I always that's that's such a
to me it's like that doesn't even mean
anything right it's like saying why is
the sky blue and it also doesn't matter
like we're all just on here we're doing
what we're doing but now if if
to be somebody that feels this and and
to love some people and and on the other
hand there's there's Miss there's
there's when you lose somebody yeah you
know that hurts so [ __ ] bad yeah and
I don't I don't like that like I've I've
had friends that I don't have anymore
and it [ __ ]
it hurts so
bad dude it hurts so bad and I know what
that feels like and dude I called my
last special no pain because I wasn't
letting myself
love I wasn't letting myself be open to
that and so I never felt pain and now
you're forced to feel pain because I
have a family because there's ups and
downs and now I love my friends and
um
and it doesn't always feel good and
people say like oh yeah but that's what
life's about you know you can't live
unless you unless you feel all of those
emotions and if you're gonna ask me
what's better
I guess it's better to feel the love
yeah because
it's Fuller you know it's like you can
you can keep eating
Skittles and candy and [ __ ] but you
gotta eat [ __ ] actual real food
otherwise you're just gonna feel like
[ __ ] eventually and
um and that's tougher you know and you
have to work [ __ ] out and it's
it's uncomfortable as [ __ ] that's the
thing too though you're you're you're
making yourself work stuff out like for
the longest time again like you lived a
life where you were rewarded by your
disconnecting and as long as long as I'm
making these people laugh like I'm doing
my job like I'm fulfilling what it
whatever it is in my mind that I'm
supposed to be doing with my life and
you're rewarded for that so why would
you do anything different because when
you go through those feelings or you
allow yourself to process those things
you're not being rewarded it hurts and
it's like you're sitting there why am I
crying in my bedroom like this doesn't
feel good but it's just it's so much
more fulfilling yeah and that was a good
you said full you feel so much more full
Yeah the more you allow yourself to to
sit in those those um in that discomfort
the the outside of your comfort zone the
more you're going to grow and the more
love you're gonna have for the people
around you because your life is just
going to be more full you're gonna have
more things that are like oh I'm glad I
experienced that I didn't think I would
I didn't think I'd like to Color Me Mine
but like you did and you're like that's
a feeling that you've never had before
and how cool is that like now you're
gonna have that feeling when you're
doing something else you're like oh I
know what I know this feeling like this
I didn't know this feeling before and
now it's here and I don't have to like
push it away or be scared of it or like
make jokes about it like this is kind of
nice I don't know man it's it's exciting
for me I mean I I I I I missed you like
you know I I when we weren't speaking
for a while like I missed you and I I
didn't feel like I could tell you that
and you said that you've lost so many
friends and you missed them what would
it be like if you told them that I mean
uh
uh I have no I have some some of them um
and some of them I just I guess I
haven't but you know I mean look alone
in this life you you live you know you
you you meet people you love people and
they fall out of your life and then
Sometimes they come back and then this
and that and like you know you uh
uh we always [ __ ] liked each other
and loved each other and and you were in
Texas for a bit and you know when that
happens then you kind of like you all
right you text and then you stop texting
and then you're like
um
and yeah you know I don't know Life's a
[ __ ] long time though huh like it's
like I'm 42 now and um I I thought for a
while I would never have kids and [ __ ]
changes you know and it's uh and it's
all hopefully for the better unless you
know
somebody gets hit by a [ __ ] train but
keep telling people you love them yeah
and look at them in the eye when you say
well you don't know you also you also
you don't want to be that annoying
spiritual guy that's always walking
around like telling people that you love
them and nobody's gonna think that about
you yeah that's true that's true because
you're not that guy that's true that's
true like sometimes we think that people
are gonna think things about us like
wait we're not giving them any credit at
all right like nobody know us be like
you're lean right nobody would say
You're nobody would think you're lean
you no you're pretty nobody would be
like I am but nobody would be like your
handsome as I'll go dude you're handsome
do you
no I no I am handsome you look better
with a mustache I never ever understood
that about people unless dashes are
weird I don't look better with them yeah
I know so you know why because you're
you
I thought you were gonna have to be in
the middle and you said no I went before
knew you're gonna have to be that's
because I know you're better than you
know yourself
you need to do just walk on yourself go
pee okay go pee
I'm
Legit
good to do this by myself dude P he's
gonna take a [ __ ]
I know I know dude because he didn't eat
cheese if you ate cheese he'd be taking
a [ __ ] I'll tell you something about
leave that open too because it's so
blisteringly hot
um what's that
yeah yeah dude if we hear fart noises
um David honestly is uh
uh great we're happy to have him on this
podcast I will tell you too uh I didn't
ever want to have guests on this podcast
and it's part of the reason why I'm
having him on this podcast is because
first of all I talk about him a lot but
also
um you know as we're talking about like
growth and life is about change and [ __ ]
like you know sometimes things need to
[ __ ] be shaken up and and stirred and
I want to have him on the podcast and
I've been wanting to so [ __ ] it I know
that maybe some of you miss me just
doing that solo [ __ ] but also it's the
holidays and like I feel like kind of
just doing this like I've been working
way too [ __ ] hard
um like it's really been getting into my
mental health
um and uh
you know I even called [ __ ] Theo
about it and we were chatting and and
and uh so you so you know I mean
business because uh he's he's Mr uh Mr
I've been working too hard and we've
been talking about it we kind of
commiserated but also you know it was a
good conversation I just [ __ ] worked
so so much and um I wanted to be kind of
just
you can leave it open you know want it
to be uh chilling uh and and kind of
take the mental load off of myself just
through the holiday seasons and in
January we'll be back with a bang
um so that's what I've been that's what
I've been doing and then I was like
David could help with that
um and I'm trying to get Kristen on
another podcast too because I think that
she would be really great uh to do uh to
do the podcast with because I may have
missed this but why don't you have this
something new is having somebody on here
like I honestly thought that I was
coming to help because I didn't think
Marco was going to be available you're
like hey you wanna you wanna really yeah
oh that's hilarious I was like all right
you just gotta tell me what to do oh
that's funny you did say that yeah no I
wanted to have you on you're cool with
being on right yeah of course you
started dinner for an hour yeah
um and I wanted to have you on because
no I was talking about because dude I
feel like I've been working too hard you
know yeah and you know I don't know it's
interesting because like as an actor
like one of the reasons why you've been
with me on the road and you've also are
able available right now is because it's
the [ __ ] cool holiday seasons and
that's everything slows the [ __ ] down in
Hollywood and you're you know if you're
not on something that you know is going
to be three months in New Zealand which
is something that you've done then
you're just going to be kind of waiting
like as an actor yeah if I didn't have
tour dates I would you would just wait
yeah from literally the week before
Thanksgiving to January 12th it's after
Sunday yeah it's usually at the end of
time because Sundance is like the end of
January it's like the 15th through the
25th so usually yeah yeah until the end
of January Hollywood's just like done
like what it sucks it's literally two
months it does so
um
so so that's one of the reasons why you
know you've been on the road and [ __ ]
because you're just like yeah I'll just
wait till the [ __ ] Hollywood kicks
back up again
um you work a lot you were in Sundance
yeah how many times a few times yeah
three times so primer obviously we'll
get to that but then I did a film called
uh Skateland oh yeah yeah and uh and
then I did a film called mad actually no
that was slam dance but slam dance goes
on at the same time yeah
um and I've been a handful of times so
wait so uh you were in so
there's primer you can close that door
now I guess so primer uh was the big one
that that was your intro to Hollywood
yeah all right if you got I've talked
about prime number primer before because
I've talked about David Sullivan it's
it's one of the best like I mean and I'm
when I said one of the best I mean top
two or three yeah time travel movies
ever yeah
um
You could argue you know everyone says
Back to the Future sure and primer was
not on that scale right you know that
was a more enjoyable film right of
course yeah primer you gotta like
seriously
you can't text you yeah you don't always
watch it with somebody right actually it
might be good but you'd be like hold on
wait what is going on it's very hard to
understand yeah which I I like because
it's a [ __ ] time travel movie yeah
right and I also the one of the reasons
why I love about it is it doesn't
explain [ __ ] to you you guys are the two
guys in it just trying to figure
everything out yourselves yeah and it's
almost like if the audience gets hit the
audience [ __ ] gets it that's what I
like about it and I think that's one of
the reasons why it's so good thank you
but so you were in this movie and this
is crazy because you were just a guy
from Texas yeah yeah I I was working I
was working for a software company and
uh I got laid off selling jacuzzis I was
um software and I got laid off and I had
like a severance package and whatever I
had money and I was like what is it that
would really make me happy and I spent
some time and I thought about it and
made me uncomfortable yeah but I kind of
sat in it for a while right and uh I had
never acted before I did a I did a a
couple of one-night plays in high school
where you're on stage for like 11
minutes and then you tear it on the set
and whatever and I was like man that was
so fun
um why'd you like it uh I just like so
weird from a software engineer yeah I
just like the idea of pretending and and
I felt like I could do no wrong because
it's like oh I'm pretending to be
somebody else like I I can I can do that
like that if they don't like my
performances like they didn't like the
character I played it's not like they
didn't like me because I was somebody
else for a little bit
um and so like I I thought if there's a
way that I can perform I think that
would be cool so yeah I was in Dallas
and I I had a picture taken and I mailed
some headshots to some casting agents
and um and producers and this was I mean
this is what two thousand yeah this was
like 2000 2001 and uh it was a black and
white picture that a guy had taken for
me and then wow yeah the director I met
him at a Starbucks and we uh we just
read he bought a few pages yeah Shane um
and he was like what are you doing
tomorrow and I'm like dude I I don't
really have much going on right now I
was like well let's let's go let's meet
up again and I will read some more stuff
and we've read some more stuff and that
was like my first audition I didn't
really I didn't even know what an
audition was yeah
um and so he was like well what are you
what are you doing for the next month or
so and I'm like dude I just got laid off
like I don't I I got time he's like well
I think I got a guy who's gonna help us
with the camera do you know anything
about filmmaking and I was like no but I
what is it that I need to know and he
was like well and he kind of goes
through all this stuff that I don't need
to know anything about but I was like
well I know how to get things like I
know how to like we need a house all
right we'll get a house we need an
office I'll get an office we need a
store yeah so I was able to kind of
facilitate the locations and and I
brought on the rest of the crew because
I had friends in Dallas like wait we're
gonna make a movie yeah I'll do that but
they had jobs too which was weird like
they would they would uh leave work
early to come help us shoot and uh and
they're also in the movie as well so if
the people everybody that made that
movie is actually in the movie
um so like when I wasn't on camera which
was very little I was on the camera the
majority of the time I was like I was
holding like a we had a really long
halogen light that we hooked up on a
stick and I was like following yeah
um or there was just or pushing the
dolly or whatever it was yeah we made it
for seven thousand dollars and it won
Sundance that's crazy yeah yeah it was
nuts
um so okay so you did that and then saw
yourself on the cover of uh what was it
used yeah USA Today yeah and then you're
like you thought you literally thought
you made it of course so I've been there
yeah when I was 19 I did I got a movie
and I was like oh I made it oh I didn't
know that and then and then it and then
it came out it didn't come out for like
seven years right well mine was like
three years yeah no but mine was
literally like let's see
I actually think mine was eight years it
just it was on why did it even come out
then because you got a little bit of
Fame I don't know what yeah Aaron Paul
was in it and then and I maybe maybe I I
don't think I had anything to do with it
I think maybe Aaron Paul did it just got
uh you know whoa and then uh did you
guys know each other or were you just
met on the movie Aaron yeah that's how
we met he was 20 I was 19. I didn't know
yeah that's why I know Aaron yeah we've
been friends forever yeah love that dude
um wow and happy for your success he's
amazing yeah um such a good I mean that
that show Breaking Bad show yeah yeah
um and um
yeah so I thought I made it and then
I'll uh you know obviously I started
stand up maybe five years later it's so
hard I lost yeah it's too hard yeah and
uh you're relying too many on on too
many other people which I'm not good at
so I started doing stand-up at a loss
and I just was what I always wanted to
do but I always figured I would like
either back door it or figure it out
later which is idiotic yeah you need to
cut your teeth in the clubs and [ __ ] but
now
um but you did it like you did it right
did you have somebody who was like dude
you got to get on stage all the time or
was that just your instinct was that
like your nature like I have to do this
well so it's different for a stand-up
than it is for a musician like a
musician you can't really I mean you can
do kind of open mics and [ __ ] but like
you don't play like like I'll play like
the Laugh Factory every night if I want
right like musicians don't play
somewhere in La every night because
they'll just like it's just not
something musicians do because they'll
either exhaust their their uh uh fan
base or they'll exhaust their ticket
sales and [ __ ] it's just like not really
like that for stand up and and coming up
the idea is to play the [ __ ] gigs and
get funny like that's why I can do this
podcast it's just me talking to nobody
I'm bombing but I don't give a [ __ ] I
still think it's funny and then so it
reaches people and they're like okay
well we actually think this is funny
right that's because I don't give a [ __ ]
if I'm bombing right right and it's
because you cut your teeth in the clubs
and the open bikes and the coffee shops
and the [ __ ] laundromats literally
yeah so uh and I found out that when you
do stand up you can just do it every
night yeah I didn't know that and then
so I started doing stand-up and I and I
would go to open mics every night yeah
and then uh the first time I did I was
23. the second time I did I was 25 and
then I just did it every day yeah uh
every day and then it got to the point
where I was doing it every like two or
three times a night yeah I'd be running
back and forth doing different clubs you
know running you know doing coffee shops
uh there were laundromats comic book
stores so fun it was so funny we would
go yeah we went to a bar somewhere in
the valley that was next there I don't
know if it's part of the gas station or
next to the gas station and the bar like
you're facing the opposite direction of
that stage yeah you were with me then
that was yeah that was I told that story
in incorrigible when there was that I
did that bar once and the woman charged
the stage I don't know if you were there
that one yeah yeah yeah
something yeah and then uh yeah oh yeah
you did talk about that on your phone
now the Press would have a field day
would be all my fall but the um but yeah
so that is
but that that is what I would do and
that was called what the [ __ ] Liquid Zoo
that's what that place was called and uh
yeah I don't know dude I I loved it and
you know I also I have I obsess about
stuff and I have an obsessive
um personality and and that was part of
that and I always thought oh this is
healthy like a healthy one stand up and
it was and I got you know I got a career
out of it and um
yeah and and it was just uh
it was it was a wild ride and it is a
wild ride but uh you know I think that
that's one of the things I love about
stand-up is that and comedy is that you
can just keep doing it and do it yeah
and you don't have to like I could book
my own dates yeah I could do literally
every night next week next next month if
I want to yeah that's that's what's when
when where we're going to Adam's wedding
it was just like dude it's going to be
in Phoenix like dude and you just you
call the club and they're like yeah okay
we'll move things around there what
nights well we usually do Saturdays he's
like nah we're gonna do a Thursday and
Friday I'm like okay yeah like that's
yes and it was so fun so fun and I'm so
grateful for the people that come out
now and I worked for free forever of
course and uh yeah I just love doing it
yeah you know and I don't know if you
find this reacting but like have you
always loved acting the most as you have
gone throughout your career no because I
I have spouts where I don't make any
money right and I I
make myself feel really shitty because
it's like oh what I'm paid to do I'm not
being paid to do anymore and nobody
wants to hire me and it doesn't feel
good because then it's like well what's
my value right now if I'm not able to
you know make a good living doing this
and and growing up I mean looking at me
you don't see me as like a supreme
athlete but like I'm a premier athlete
okay all right yeah I mean my my um
yeah football at what level at Baylor
division one division one okay now when
you find out what position he plays
that's important okay I was a division
one football player yeah
um we'll leave out what he did yeah but
it rhymes with
picker
six kicker you were a kicker so you were
used 10 seconds in every game yeah I I
wish that were true but I I yeah uh you
could kick the [ __ ] out of a football I
could I could but I played
that's not important basically I'm sorry
I learned at an early age that like oh
you're as valuable as what it is that
you can contribute and I never took into
consideration like oh I can contribute
as a human being because that doesn't
make sense to me especially as a child
and like even an early early like 20s
and 30s like
that no I gotta make money I gotta get
paid I gotta get the big house in the
car and everything and that made me feel
good
um and then moving out here and being
broke after three months crazy yeah I'm
like
oh what what do I do now and I still
have yeah it still kind of hits me that
like even now like I I yeah I have some
down time and I just came off a show
that's gonna be a big hit but like I
don't know my next job and it's it's a
little bit scary and it's um I I used to
I used to teach and coach and and
interact with a lot of actors a lot and
and with the pandemic I just kind of
stopped that and I was just kind of
focusing on me and what I could bring as
an actor but
um yeah it's it's actually was great
timing for me being around you again and
and man you just I don't know you light
me up like you really you you get me
going I got on stage yeah
that was something I never ever would do
we had you we had you introduced the
show in Albany oh that was so scary man
my heart's just racing thinking about it
now I don't really oh yeah I was I I
don't know what that is I I I think I
think it's because I mean it's probably
the same reason why I've never really
finished a script because like writing
one yeah I've never finished one I've
written but it's like I've I've read so
many good scripts that like why would I
think that I could be that good but like
after being around you and and so many
great comedians for so many years I'm
like I could never be that so why why
the hell would I even want to do that
and I've never had the desire to do that
um and then we kind of started as a joke
but but Lulu wasn't able to come to the
oh yeah yeah it was like Mike was just
like yeah just introduce me me just go
up then introduce me and I'm like I
can't do that and then the thing was he
made it really simple for me he was like
dude just go out there because we were
doing bits and it was like dude welcome
to the show you know yeah yeah but Mike
was just like just go out there and say
welcome Mike linochi and I was like oh I
could do that and I took a small step
into something that I thought was very
uncomfortable and very much something
that scared the [ __ ] out of me and it
did like even so funny yeah even I guess
it does though like if I were to think
like I mean there was a thousand people
at that show right so yeah
if I I don't even like a lot of the
times when I'm on stage I'm less nervous
than I am in the day for other things
like genuinely and I know that sounds so
like that I'm trying to be cute saying
this [ __ ] but it's a hundred percent
true like if I'm on stage now at this
point in my career that hour at least I
know what I'm doing right and also in
knowing you you have spent more time
doing that than you have probably
anything else either thinking about it
or performing true like so of course
that would be you would feel more
comfortable than sitting on the edge of
your bed and asking yourself why you're
unhappy like of course it's funny too
it's a bit uh I I was joking around to
my therapist recently and she was like
don't she I was like yeah you know I
know we're not supposed to
compartmentalize but man sometimes when
I have rough days
um like in Denver when we were like I
had a [ __ ] [ __ ] day in Denver and I
was like and that was my biggest show
yet it was 4 500 people and I was like
man thank God I'm able to come home
mentalized and we all laughed and she
was like you got to be careful of that
and and then we ended up talking about
something else and then she was like I
want to go back to that because I want
you to make sure that yes of course it's
good to compartmentalize you when you're
on the road you have to compartmentalize
and do your job so you're able to do
your job and do your career but careful
coming off stage that that's when it
stops and she's right about that because
it's easy for me to get sucked into that
adoration and then get off stage and you
know I'm joking but I also like I I'm
joking when I'm like [ __ ] yeah like I'll
walk off stage like like Chappelle Lacey
the other day I I went on
I went on stage and then after Chappelle
Chappelle had a great set she probably
see a different comedian some of you
guys thinking Dave Chappelle not Dave
Chappelle
um and so
I he had a great set I went on I had a
great set I got off stage and I and I
said after I I forgot to say it I said
hey I heard when I was getting off stage
I heard people literally say Chappelle
who and I said this to Chappelle and and
he laughed you know and I'm joking of
course but like
to I have to be careful of like playing
a character in real life all the time
yeah because then I'm not being a real
person yeah and um so yeah so anyway uh
you being up there felt very real
because it's not your job and you you
were you were you got off stage and you
were your heart was really pumping it's
interesting too because when I first
started that's how I felt but I have no
so I know how that feels right but I
just don't feel that way anymore yeah
yeah but that makes sense yeah yeah yeah
because you have done that for so long
right and like I said you're constantly
thinking about what's funny it's a 10
000 hours thing right yeah yeah that's
so it doesn't surprise me that that's
where you're most comfortable and it
doesn't surprise me too well you're the
most uncomfortable when you're doing
things that you don't want to do yeah
because you just haven't done them yeah
and I was like why don't I just do the
[ __ ] I'm good at that's what I fall back
into it's like but then the truth is
like for instance for you you're one of
your traits is I like to try everything
if you didn't like to try everything you
might not be an actor right now that's
true yeah that's true yeah yeah it's
very we learn yeah we learned dude yeah
because I them
I never would have thought that like
coming from a small town in East Texas
like you you you don't think really
outside your world and you're just like
you know even even after I moved to LA I
talked to my dad and he'd be like ah you
know you got to think about coming home
yeah you know you know your brother can
get you on at the bank wow you know you
ought to think about coming up because
you know for the first few years uh he
would be like oh you should be in that
Clint Eastwood movie and it's just like
yeah Dad that's not how it works like
yeah I would love to be in a cleaning
hilarious parents would be like why
don't you get get SNL yeah yeah
constantly and and it it is one of those
things where you're just like well yeah
maybe I maybe I should
scary yeah
what else do you want to try doing
you know to be honest with you you
already know no no no after I did that
and the the
I'm not an anxious person but like that
Rush that I felt the 30 seconds I was on
stage yeah and even I had a it wasn't
even a joke I had nothing to say I was
literally going to go out there and say
ladies and gentlemen Michael but I went
out there and I was like
how y'all doing right whatever I said
hey how's everybody doing and then I got
like a response and I'm like oh all
right well maybe I should do something
else yeah that's it yeah yeah yeah
that's it yeah and then I did something
else and it didn't work and I was like
okay I gotta get out of here yeah and so
I just immediately I didn't even I don't
even think I said your name I was like
yeah I was like I've known these guys
um but very disrespectful to not say my
name yeah yeah
um but I there's something there that
really kind of uh that really kind of
excited me and I I think maybe I've been
scared to do it
um but I think I want to do more live
because I've never I've never done I
haven't done a play you said you did it
in high school right there were one act
place it was like literally on stage for
10 minutes okay so I think I want to do
a play I think I want to get in front of
an audience and do something like that
um I haven't had really had the
opportunity to do it because I haven't
really focused my energy in that
direction but man it was cool it was
really cool so I don't know yeah it's
the best job to me it's the best job in
the world yeah but stand up I still
don't and I get asked that all the time
because are you a stand-up why don't you
just stand up you're funny
um and I'm just like nah it's not my my
art form yeah but maybe
maybe after I do a play and then I get
more comfortable on stage maybe I'll
I'll go and try some jokes but also I
know how much work it is and in a weird
way I don't
um I don't want to cheat the system
because I know you and like oh what what
he's doing 10 minutes before Chris like
that you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I put you on after me I put you on
after me I do an hour and then you'd
come on you have to do six hot minutes
or in the middle I'd be like in the
middle of a joke when they're all like
I'd be like you guys you don't get to
hear this now I got to bring my buddy
David Sullivan up and you come up and
you're like what's it do with fruit
you know when you're dipping you know
when you're dipping and you're working
on your fence
uh because it broke because the cattle
got out what the [ __ ] is up with Spurs
you know when you're like walking and
like you trip and then your calf gets
all bloody yeah write this down yeah
well hey by the way I will be selling
jacuzzis uh
after the show I have one so far
um you can buy it highest bidder
um so yeah yeah they're good jokes yeah
I think I'm gonna do that yeah there you
go you guys thank you very much for
watching thank you guys thanks for
having me buddy this is really fun it
was great yeah the first that was really
good non-family non-blood yeah we'll cut
it so you you look good but uh you don't
need to cut it and uh also thank God you
can't see his bottom half he's dressed
like Adam Sandler on a bad day honestly
he's got [ __ ] basketball shorts on
and Cherry socks which are red and blue
and then shoes that have orange in it
dude the guys are you blind dude so
thank you for coming David Sullivan and
thank you for uh ripping with us life
rips go to chrysalia.com get those
tickets the tour tickets uh I'm gonna be
in Portland and San Diego and Brea and
uh Seattle and Sugarland Texas and
Midland Texas and uh Austin Texas dude I
love that you're going to Texas so yeah
bro I love Texas yeah well I have a lot
of people I got a lot of friends that
want to come see you yeah okay cool this
one uh they can come uh and also uh New
York and Chicago and [ __ ] but thank you
very much subscribe like and uh thanks
for listening thanks for watching hey
guys that's it for the episode for
YouTube if you want to catch the uncut
the uncensored the raw the unedited
version all you got to do is go over
going over to our patreon that's
patreon.com crystalia and you will get
the rest of this episode and you will
also get the extra episodes
um that are one one we do one a month
for only patreon people so and you get
that for just six dollars a month so
that's patreon.com crystalia thanks a
lot
[Music]
thank you
[Music]